well we're here with past us champion
alexander only shook alexander last year
we had some interesting formats and
everything and this year back to the The
Plain Jane the round robin is that the
format you prefer yes I think so i think
this they're on robin tournament whoever
wins the tournament is when I have the
best tournament and will be the
strongest player at least of these
periods of time and this year because
everyone's playing everyone my question
would be would you prefer to play the
higher rated players to beginning in a
tournament or at the end of the
tournament I guess in the beginning
probably yeah it's just better way as
far as colors go would you prefer to get
more wipes than blacks or would you
prefer your whites to come against the
stronger players um still having six
whites it's better doesn't matter whom
you play it's just overall six six
versus four it's better they have six
points right even if they come against
the lowrider player yes yes maybe
especially because I'm not sure not sure
what's color actually it's all depends
on your styling us and looking ahead it
seems like this year might be the
strongest Olympiad team you've had in
quite some time we've got the prospect
of having somebody like Sarah one with
you know 35 40 years of chess experience
playing boards five does that excite you
about the prospects of American chest
going towards or so I agree little team
is very competitive
and very strong but there are other six
seven teams that also very strong and
you look for the excitement is saying
who ends up being your teammates as it
seems like the top three are in but yeah
this will be interesting especially
because this tournament will decide who
is actually going to be there in the
queue well no matter who it is I'm sure
you guys have a great showing in
Istanbul but before that I know you've
got to focus on your next two weeks in
st. Louis so good luck trying to win
your next US Championship we wish you
well this year you know try to the one
best thank you my thanks